it's baby number three
for social media's favorite parents
the good news was revealed in wild john
legend's latest music video released on
thursday
after fans spotted chrissy teigen's
pregnancy bumps
[Music]
john and chrissy are already parents to
four-year-old daughter luna
and two-year-old son miles who are both
major fan favorites on their parents
instagram accounts
it's just fun to see the evolution of us
as a as a couple
through all these videos it's been
chronicling our family's
growth and our journey the couple did an
amazing job keeping the new
secret with john remaining tight-lipped
with e.t
just moments before the video dropped
there's been enough time together you
never know
the egot winner was completely sly when
asked if he and chrissy have thought
about expanding the family
you guys seem to have just so much fun
you've made
a good situation out of pandemic this
summer any plans there to
add to the team over there maybe give
we don't plan these things uh we haven't
planned them right now but uh
uh we'll see what happens yeah i guess
we will
the announcement comes on the heels of
katy perry's own musical pregnancy
revelation
earlier this year in her video never
worn white
and john did tell e.t another reason why
the music video is special for the
expecting couple
and the video was directed by a good
friend of ours named nabil elderkin
who was the person who introduced us in
the first place many years
ago and uh he directed the all of me
video as well
and so uh it's all coming back
uh full circle
of you it seems like it's such a full
circle from
stereo all of me now with wild beautiful
thing
um and you two look mighty beautiful in
this video i guess
thank you very much concept of it can
you give us a little gift
before it goes well um of course the
song is called wild and
and it's about being passionate about
someone that you love
and um nabil's idea was to
um use these two horses as kind of uh
symbols of of that passion and so
a lot of the video features these
beautiful horses we shot it down in
mexico
and uh nabeel's just a really gifted
filmmaker
and so i'm excited for people to see it
all come together